a short moment of hope
and then relief as rescuers pull this
man out from the debris alive
he's one of the lucky ones
several people have been reported dead
and dozens mainly employees of the
rishiganga power plant are still missing
this amateur video shows the moment the
small dam was swept away
after part of a mountain glacier broke
unleashing an avalanche of water and
debris
it then cut further through the area
hitting the hydroelectric power plant
in the valley below
i looked up and down but couldn't see
anything but then after five minutes i
saw something that looked like a scene
from a bollywood film
50 to 100 people were running for their
lives but couldn't be saved as
the river engulfed them
the tragedy happened in the tapivan area
of the state of uttarakhand
in northern india this region in the
himalayas is prone to flash floods
and landslides
the situation here is still dangerous
people are leaving their homes and are
fleeing toward the forest
they're taking their belongings
including their quilts and mattresses
locals from neighboring villages are
worried the dam near them could also
collapse
while rescue operations are ongoing the
government has told the locals to
shelter near the forest
as they fear the disaster could strike
again
our correspondent nimisha jaswal joins
us now uh from
delhi uh nimisha how are rescue
operations going
well there are there are multiple teams
still working
continuously at the location where the
disaster took place
there are teams from the border police
force the army
the navy has sent divers to look for
survivors or for bodies
and there are of course the disaster
response forces from the state
and the national level as well now while
there have been around 170 people that
are missing because they are counting
the laborers from one power project
from two different power projects that
was hit in the debris
there is also of course concern that
this debris being carried further down
could have caused more damage as well
thousands have been evacuated
and the surge continues several people
were trapped
within tunnels as well 12 of these have
been rescued
but dozens more us the the efforts on
going to rescue dozens more
well could this maybe have been foreseen
and could people have
been evacuated in time
there was no warning right before this
particular
incident it happened so quickly that the
glacier burst led to an
avalanche and to a massive flood that
people did not have time to react as we
can see
from the visuals from yesterday however
there have been
long-standing warnings by activists by
local journalists by environmental
campaigners
saying that construction along this
water body
is dangerous and that there isn't there
is a way to
prevent such disasters in the longer
term
by rethinking this construction in back
in 2013 there were massive
monsoon floods in the region which
caused the loss of life of close to 6
000 people
which was a grim reminder about the
conditions in this ecologically
sensitive area
there were efforts made after that to
institute new rules to prevent further
construction
however the current modi government has
been criticized
for rolling back some of these or some
of these rules when they came into power
for the first time back in 2014.
nimisha as well in delhi for us thank
you nimisha